[Música]
Bienvenidos a la entrevista de France 24
desde el foro económico mundial en Davo
Suiza nos encontramos hoy con Julio José
Prado él es el ministro de producción o
comercio inversiones y pesca del Ecuador
Muchas gracias por atendernos señor
ministro y le pregunto primero que han
logrado toda esta semana para Ecuador en
este foro económico mundial Bueno
muchísimas gracias por la entrevista
hemos estado aquí con el presidente
Guillermo lasso cuatro ministros de
ministro de relaciones exteriores
ministro de ambiente el ministro de
economía y finanzas y yo en esta
delegación para poder presentar el
entorno de negocios de inversiones
acercarnos hacia el mundo no solo
empresarial sino el mundo político
reinsertando al Ecuador en las
relaciones internacionales en el
comercio y en todo el mundo de las
inversiones hemos conversado con varias
empresas multinacionales en lo
específico en los temas de comercio Por
ejemplo yo he podido tener reuniones
bilaterales con los ministros de
comercio de inversiones de de Singapur
de Japón de Canadá de Estados Unidos
para poder avanzar en la agenda
comercial que te puedo comentar En un
momento más así que en realidad una
semana muy intensa que muy intensa que
está ya llegando a su finalización claro
acaban de cerrar un tlc con china
también están mirando hacia Estados
Unidos México cuéntenos un poco Cómo van
los avances de todos estos tratados de
libre comercio Mira dentro de la agenda
de competitividad que se llama Ecuador
compite que es la más integral la más
amplia que hemos visto al menos en los
últimos 20 años en Ecuador un tema
esencial es poder abrir la economía del
Ecuador al mundo por eso el presidente
lasso nos ha propuesto una agenda
intensa de diez nuevos acuerdos
comerciales durante este periodo del
gobierno durante estos últimos meses ya
hemos cerrado dos de ellos El caso de
China el caso de Costa Rica y Y tenemos
muy avanzado el proceso tanto con Corea
del Sur como con México Corea estará a
punto de cerrarse en los próximos tres
meses y con México seguimos en
conversaciones con un avance cercano al
99% de ese acuerdo comercial con China
de economía más grande del mundo muy
interesante el mercado sin duda para el
Ecuador muchas oportunidades de
exportaciones alguna sensibilidades
también del lado de las importaciones y
por eso no he hecho un manejo muy
técnico muy adecuado de esa negociación
el cual la cual hemos cerrado en 10
meses y dentro de poco en los próximos
dos meses a tres meses tendremos ya la
firma de ese acuerdo comercial como
explicarle a la gente los beneficios que
trae precisamente un tratado de libre
comercio con estos países hay Quienes se
sienten de pronto temerosos de que
puedan llegar productos muy baratos y
que afecten a la industria sin duda Mira
sobre todo el caso de China No es cierto
ha generado ciertas dudas iniciales
cuando no anunciamos al inicio del año
pasado la negociación pero es una
negociación muy balanceada primero por
el lado de exportaciones vamos a tener
acceso inmediato para el 99
99% de la oferta exportable del Ecuador
un mercado de más de mil cuatrocientos
millones de potenciales consumidores del
lado de las importaciones sin duda que
hemos tenido que tener mucho una
negociación y hemos logrado dejar
excluidos cerca de
860 partidas que el Ecuador le parecen
que son muy sensibles para poderlas
abrir con china ahí tenemos varias
partidas relacionadas con productos por
ejemplo textiles con calzado con
cerámica metal mecánica y algunos de
otros productos manufactureros sobre
todo de la Sierra central del Ecuador
esto representa más del 10% de la oferta
productiva de nuestro país con lo cual
aseguramos que este acuerdo comercial es
beneficioso para la exportaciones y
además Cuida la sensibilidades
industriales de nuestro país Bueno uno
de los temas principales de este foro
económico mundial ha sido el cambio cli
Qué está haciendo Ecuador para que su
industria transite hacia energías más
limpias mira este es un gran anuncio que
hemos hecho con el liderazgo de Ecuador
que ha participado con tres otros países
o bloques para formar la alianza o la
como se llama la coalición de ministros
de comercio exterior en favor de el
cambio climático No es cierto para
protegernos justamente de todas las
problemas que han venido por el lado de
el cambio climático en este caso Ecuador
Kenia y la Unión Europea han promovido
esta coalición histórica que se acaba de
lanzar aquí en el World economic Forum
en davos y que lo que busca es
justamente juntarle a más de 50 países
inicialmente y Esperamos que se junten
muchos más 50 ministros de comercio
exterior para encontrar mecanismos que
permitan trabajar para mitigar el cambio
climático desde el punto de vista de la
exportaciones las importaciones el
comercio los servicios y demás Así que
por primera vez se lanza iniciativa en
davos y yo espero que no solo sean
diálogos conversaciones que son
importantes sino acciones concretas para
poder avanzar sobre un acuerdo en temas
de acuerdos comerciales temas de
exportaciones temas de comercio pero con
una visión siempre sostenible hacia el
ambiente no ministro hablemos de otro
tema que ha sido gran protagonista acá
en este foro que es la guerra en Ucrania
Cómo hace un año desde hace un año para
acá Cómo ha afectado a la industria de
cómo ha afectado el comercio de Ecuador
esta guerra Mira a inicios del año
pasado justo antes de la invasión de
Rusia Ucrania el comercio con Rusia
representaba nuestro tercer socio
comercial eran más de mil millones de
dólares en exportaciones del ecuador
hacia Rusia Así que para nosotros la
guerra ha sido tremendamente perjudicial
del punto de vista del comercio hoy por
hoy ya podemos ver con las cifras
cerradas al año 2022 que Rusia ha sido
desplazado al quinto lugar y de hecho
Colombia ha tomado ese lugar no es
cierto y hoy hoy por hoy Colombia ha
desplazado a Rusia siendo ya Rusia El
quinto socio comercial han caído
fuertemente las exportaciones y
evidentemente también las importaciones
por ese lado pero un tema que siempre
dijimos desde el inicio Es que para el
Ecuador en las relaciones
internacionales poder mantener los
valores los principios de no
intervención de paz de democracia son
muy importantes incluso por encima de
las relaciones económicas que sin duda
se han visto afectado así que por eso es
que el Ecuador fue de los primeros en el
mundo en condenar la invasión de Rusia
en Ucrania y evidentemente queremos
mantener relaciones comerciales
políticas en el futuro también con Rusia
pero lo que hace falta es que se ponga
cualquier agresión esa es una condición
sin ecuación que la ha puesto el
presidente lazo por encima de las
relaciones directamente comerciales yo
recuerdo que uno de los sectores que más
se vio afectado fue El Bananero que han
podido bananeros en este último año para
recuperarse de esa de esos impactos de
la guerra Mira sin duda que en lista
digamos de sectores que se han visto más
afectados en las exportaciones hacia
Rusia el sector Bananero más de 700
millones de dólares en exportaciones el
sector camaronero el sector cacaotero y
el sector florícola Esos son los cuatro
sectores Donde ha habido más
afectaciones en Rusia en el primer caso
en el sector Bananero Sí hemos tenido un
impacto ha habido una caída de las
exportaciones hacia ese mercado que
bordean entre el menos ocho y menos 10%
Comparado a inicios del año pasado los
bananeros han logrado con el apoyo del
gobierno de las oficinas comerciales de
cancillería encontrar nuevos mercados
sobre todo en Europa no es cierto lo que
ha facilitado de alguna forma
o evitado que caiga mucho más las
exportaciones y también en el Asia por
eso es que lo que nosotros decimos es
que es tan importante tener más acuerdos
comerciales si hubiésemos tenido en el
Ecuador una economía más abierta y con
más acceso a otros mercados sin
aranceles para el banano para el camarón
para el cacao para todos nuestros
productos pues evidentemente se puede
reemplazar más fácilmente ese mercado
que ha entrado en una crisis en un shock
específico no y por eso la estrategia de
abrir nuevos mercados es lo que
proponemos en el mediano y largo plazo
en el corto plazo mercados que permitan
reemplazar de alguna forma el mercado
ruso es lo que se ha tratado de hacer y
eso es lo que se ha logrado en forma
bastante adecuada
ministro otro tema también es el de la
pandemia ya se puede decir que estamos
en una etapa diferente de la pandemia
pero en su momento afectó mucho Sobre
todo a las pequeñas y medianas empresas
qué ha pasado en este último año con
esas empresas se han recuperado mira lo
primero es que la política primera que
puso el presidente lasso Tan pronto ganó
las elecciones hace casi 20 meses era la
reactivación económica inmediata a
través de la vacunación Ecuador ha sido
reconocido a nivel global como uno de
los países que mejor lo hizo con la
campaña de vacunación con liderazgo de
presidente eh la diplomacia de la vacuna
como se conoció esto a nivel
internacional y esto nos permitió
reabrir la economía muy rápidamente
ahora es cierto No es cierto que ha
habido un un impacto en varias de las
cadenas productivas a nivel de empleo a
nivel de destrucción incluso de de
empresas por el covid pero
ventajosamente lo que vemos en todos los
indicadores económicos en ventas en
creación de empresas en generación de
empleo es que ya hemos retornado a
niveles prepandemia en el Ecuador quizá
del indicador que nos falta todavía
recobrar es la creación de empleo no ahí
todavía hay empresas que lastimosamente
sobre todo medianas empresas y grandes
empresas que tuvieron que despedir
empleados durante la pandemia Y si bien
se han aumentado en forma importante y
se han recuperado más de 500.000 empleos
durante estos 20 meses de gobierno pues
sin duda que tenemos que seguir haciendo
un esfuerzo para que las empresas puedan
contratar más y mejor empleados un tema
que hicimos directamente
en los primeros meses de gobierno hace
18 meses en realidad fue bajar los
costos de producción para la
reactivación productiva cómo lo hicimos
a través de la reducción arancelaria
unilateral del Ecuador más grande que se
ha visto en la historia de nuestro país
fueron 667 subpartidas arancelarias que
bajaron inmediatamente a cero materias
primas de insumos bienes de capital
herramientas maquinarias bajaron de
precio para que las empresas puedan
reactivarse justo cuando venían saliendo
de la pandemia eso fue muy reconocido y
ha sido una de las políticas que ha
ayudado a la reactivación económica y
finalmente hay una política de los
bancos centrales de Elevar las tasas de
interés para controlar la inflación Pero
esto muchas veces afecta sobre todas las
a estas empresas de las que estamos
hablando Cuál es la situación en Ecuador
y es pertinente de seguir subiendo tasas
para bajar la inflación
independientemente de que esto cause
estos consecuencias Mira para nosotros
en el Ecuador hemos tenido un manejo de
la macroeconomía muy prudente durante
estos últimos 20 meses poner la casa en
orden como la llamado el presidente lazo
nos ha permitido tener una de las
inflaciones más bajas de América Latina
y entre las más bajas del mundo en el
año 2022 este año 2023 el fmi y el Banco
Mundial proyectan que la inflación del
Ecuador va a estar bordeando el uno por
ciento uno dos por ciento lo cual
significará que estaremos entre las
economías del mundo que tendrán la
inflación más baja incluso solo después
del Japón según lo que se proyecta por
el fmi Así que lo bueno es que nosotros
tenemos una economía resiliente tenemos
una economía fuerte y si bien hemos
visto efectos inmediatos en las cadenas
de abastecimiento por el aumento de los
precios a nivel internacional eso no ha
afectado directamente como en otros
países a el Ecuador Eso es lo bueno por
el lado de tasas de interés sí es cierto
que con el aumento de tasas de interés
en el mundo se ha incrementado el costo
de financiamiento y sobre todo para el
Ecuador el gran problema que seguimos
teniendo es que el riesgo país está por
encima de los mil puntos si bien ha
bajado frente a lo que tuvimos en junio
del año pasado cuando hubo las
manifestaciones sociales e indígenas del
Ecuador que se disparó ese riesgo país
por encima de los 1.700 puntos eso ha
hecho que el costo del financiamiento a
las tasas de interés en Ecuador también
crezcan pero una vez que vaya bajando Y
hoy por hoy ya estamos en cerca de mil
puntos de riesgo país nosotros creemos
que dentro de poco ya veremos una
reducción por debajo de ese límite de
los mil que nos ha generado un costo de
endeudamiento para la estrategia de
competitividad que ha propuesto el
presidente lasso el tener inflación baja
que no haya devaluaciones que hayan
costos más bajos de financiamiento es
esencial para que más empresas puedan
financiarse Así que Esperamos que este
año eh con inflación baja sin un riesgo
de devaluación para el Ecuador y con un
riesgo país que caiga las tasas de
interés locales también puedan ir
bajando y ayudar al financiamiento
Muchas gracias ministro por estar con
nosotros
Muchísimas gracias por la entrevista a
ustedes también gracias por su sintonía
esta y otras entrevistas en France
24.com